foreign
Boston area town with an excess of
credentialed hyper-educated liberals
this is affluent not effluent
maybe both could be both the level of
masking is insane 100 of librarians oh
man
I was in a affluent
town on the west coast with an excess of
credentialed hyper-educated liberals
two days ago and I went into a bookstore
that I'd been in 15 years ago
and it made me so sad
so sad and it's like the book people so
I'm going to read this question but you
say to Librarians all of the employees
no not all of the employees many of the
employees were masked as well in this
bookstore and I actually I had I took
two actually the books that were
prominently displayed I I asked Zach if
he wanted them for Christmas so I'm
gonna just look this up sorry guys
um where I didn't even tell you this
Brett
I've got a message from Ukraine by
Vladimir zielinski I open it boy it's a
doozy
um
and then I have
white women everything you already know
about your own racism and how to do
better
by Regina Jackson and Sarah Rowe oh no
yeah um and it sucks like I can't choose
can I have both
but so I thought I'd like I went up to
the desk I'm like I'd like to know if
you have 100 gatherers Guide to the 21st
century
um and he's like
Century Hunter
gather what like okay it turns out they
did though and it's like oh yeah I think
I actually man I think it's in the
science section or maybe the psychology
section I'm like oh that would be cool
so it's not in the science section
unfortunately uh it's in the psychology
section where it doesn't go but it was
actually a space out on the Shelf nice
so yeah this anyway
um yes book culture like the book people
have become the most compliant and like
this is not what books are for they're
sucky yeah so anyway I'm I'm rant over
I'm gonna read the question from the
beginning I'm going to start wearing a
Lone Ranger mask you know I believe in
masking but just not the way they do
yes one of the last local business
holdouts here still requiring masks is
an anarchist book star
that's there it is that's it in a
nutshell thank you Melinda that's like
that's like I think we're done to the
term nutshell
okay Mary Ellen writes I live in an
affluent Boston area town with an excess
a credentialed hyper-educated liberals
the level of masking is insane 100 of
librarians 40 to 50 of rando grocery
Shoppers 15 plus percent of people
walking outside
some seem broken Beyond hope like the
masked woman and Trader Joe's who
literally ran away when I commented in
passing to the flowers in her cart were
beautiful I was unmasked what do you
think is wrong with them that's the
question
uh yeah well
they are they are broken they've been
broken by an environment in you know now
let's start here
there are two kinds of people in the
world now there are about 50 000
different useful things you can say
after you've decided to dichotomize the
world into two types of people there are
two types of people in the world they're
an infinite number of two types of
people in the world exactly
um
but there are those
whose reality
is a mixture of
physical phenomena and their
implications and social phenomena and
their implications
and then there are people whose reality
is entirely social and they look normal
because socially speaking all of the
physical ramifications getting coded
into some social thing
and so people who are completely social
in their orientation function in a world
where physics happens but when the
social World goes completely batshit
crazy
the people who are a balance between a
physical world and social World reality
have some chance of grounding themselves
people who are mostly or entirely social
have nothing to with which to Anchor and
so they end up being dragged into this
Collective insanity and in this case the
collective Insanity was corporate and
governmental in nature it came through
every channel all at once it came with a
threat so the fact that lots of people
who had no alternative toolkit are just
like signing up for crazy you know
nobody ever gave the all clear so
they're still crazy yeah you know yep
yep that's right
um
to your there are two types of people in
the world Point uh glenden writes one
that I'm very I'm very fond of uh there
are two types of people in the world one
those who can extrapolate from limited
data
very nice
it makes me laugh every time I see it
um
see it's 112. uh there's a couple of
just quick comments and then let's try
to get through maybe two more questions
and apologies that we're still missing a
solid third of them
um
I've lost my place here we go
thoughts on use of lab leak hypothesis
versus Lab Escape hypothesis the prior
may be interpreted as accidental
accidental or intentional the latter
more encompassing happy holidays
everybody
yeah it's an important distinction and
I'll just say uh my feeling is we are
obligated to stick with the more
generous
less no he's saying that lab leak could
be accidental or intentional but Lab
Escape actually
use it because because it's a bigger
solution and I agree the problem is it's
less familiar and so right so I I so I
think where you were going was we should
use the bigger one but the bigger one is
less familiar so I think you're gonna
you're gonna argue for lab leak because
it's what well but I arrived no I also
think that there's a game afoot that we
have to survive and the game is
you will be induced into embracing
something ahead of the evidence and then
you will be crucified for it and so the
point is the evidence for lab leak is
all but incontrovertible the evidence
for something Beyond is non-existent as
far as I know right I leave open the
possibility I'm waiting to see evidence
of it until then I will say its lab leak
could be worse but yep it's lab leak
that's the thing we have evidence for
and that's an important distinction okay
I will point out a quote from Men In
Black and a person is smart people are
dumb panicky dangerous animals and you
know it that's right
um someone on here asked how we keep the
cats from scratching the sofa and
someone else pointed out that this
leather is really really thick because
we say it when we read the ad for all
four minutes true we're not just making
that up that's absolutely true but they
don't try in part because
um two things
um we have really good cats now all cats
will try to scratch things
um
they um they have scratching posts and
they actually like their scratching
posts like they actually do do their
stretches and we encourage them but we
also we haven't had to do it for a while
um have spray bottles of water and we
shoot them and uh when they go after
things they're not supposed to go after
and they learn fast because they're not
dumb unlike um no like Anthony fauci
they're not Dumb Bunnies but they're
also much nicer Mathies
at least you know what they're on about
yeah okay Zach we're going to go on for
a couple more minutes
um okay it you're still going to try to
catch the 150 or something yeah Barry
okay 155 okay instead of Shadow CDC
might I suggest the intellectual dark
CDC
okay nice
um
quickly two more
now that AB 2098 in California passed
designating the dissemination of
misinformation or disinformation related
to the SARS Kobe 2 coronavirus or
covid-19 has unprofessional conduct for
Physicians warranting loss of license
holy [ __ ] I can tell that hell what's
that I did I at least knew that the bill
said that I didn't know that it passed
yeah it's passed uh apparently
how long until other blue team States
will follow suit now that elections are
over New York has a full docket of code
regulations ready for the new session we
are very very concerned with the
mandating of the job for school next
year I have a huge fear that the state
will go after homeschooling directly
making the barrier to entry so
ridiculous that parents will have to
fold and get their kids the jab do you
think this is just out of the realm of
possibility
no I'm afraid not Andrea I do not think
that is outside of the realm of
possibility
yeah almost nothing is in fact
um there was a really terrifying
video out of New Zealand
that I saw yesterday at least in which
some member of the New Zealand federal
government is inviting people if they
think any of their friends have been
radicalized have any sort of extreme
views believing can you know conspiracy
theories that they should be reported
the federal government in New Zealand
yes man she is a horror wow this is a
nightmare that woman yeah this was this
was pretty shocking wow the Prime
Minister whatever her name is it just
wasn't the Prime Minister saying okay
but presumably she's chill with it uh oh
my God yeah it was pretty it was pretty
scary God
hey guys that was a clip from our
monthly private q a that you can get
access to at my Heather Heinz patreon
and you can also get access there to all
of the past paid subscriber content so
please consider joining us there
did you mention that these private Q as
are the key to living a better life and
living to tell the tale I forgot to do
that these private q and A's are in fact
the key to living a better life and what
living to tell the tale living to tell
the tale go ahead Live to Tell the tale
join us there see ya